if I could have your attention please
we're going to begin my name is Neil
Arner I'm a teaching fellow for this
course you will recognize me I'm
obviously not Miroslav Volf our lead
professor is away in China we can
probably forgive him for being absent
he's at a Beijing forum academic
conference devoted to world peace so it
seems like a legitimate relatively
legitimate excuse to be absent however I
am pleased to be joined today by John
Grimm joint professor from the divinity
and management divinity and forestry
schools who will be speaking after me
today our schedule for today will be
just like most of our prior classes
however we have a little like multimedia
going on as well so I will provide some
introductory remarks professor Graham
will also speak then we're going to
watch a brief video that Professor Grimm
has brought after the break will resume
for our Q&A in our normal fashion my
introductory remarks will aim to help
you learn two things first I hope to
help you to see some of the
interconnections between today's focus
on ecological sustainability and various
other of our course themes second I want
to provide you some categories with
which to think about the ways that
faiths can promote ecological
sustainability before commencing I will
offer a working definition of ecological
sustainability I understand ecological
sustainability to be a lifestyle that
allows future generations the same
quality of life and access to natural
resources that we currently enjoy again
I take ecological sustainability to be a
lifestyle that allows future generations
the same quality of life and access to
natural resources that we currently
enjoy Gus Speth the former dean of the
Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies describes an
ecologically sustainable lifestyle as
quote living off nature's income rather
than consuming nature's capital I will
now begin by surveying how today's theme
relates to four of our prior course
topics and two upcoming topics first of
all globalization and ecology on the one
hand current ecological crises are high
nning people's subjective sense of being
globally interconnected for example in
the late 1980s a global alarm was raised
about the depletion of atmospheric ozone
representatives of numerous nations work
together quickly to coordinate an
international effort to limit the
release of chlorofluorocarbons that were
destroying the ozone layer on the other
hand the influence between ecology and
globalization also runs in the opposite
direction and awareness of belonging to
one world has inspired some people to
pursue ecological sustainability this
photograph taken by astronauts in the
Apollo 8 lunar orbiting mission is
widely credited with helping inspire the
environmental movement in the early
1970s this image was used in the first
Earth Day events because it visually
suggests that humans are shipmates
aboard this precious vessel of Earth
that is sailing through an otherwise
harsh and lifeless universe so in some
respects concerns about ecology are
promoting a greater subjective sense of
being a global community and in other
respects our awareness of being a global
community has motivated concern for our
environmental impact secondly global
corporations and ecology the burgeoning
of corporations over the last 150 years
is largely responsible for increasing
the scale and pace at which humans have
been able to alter the natural
environment oh no the music's back
that's great unexpectedly do that okay
yeah we wouldn't work when I needed it
before class
corporations have enabled current levels
of pollution deforestation overfishing
and resource depletion in general yet
advocates of ecological modernization
theory claim that the vast influence of
corporations might also be leveraged to
promote ecological sustainability
corporations can for example develop and
then transport around the globe green
technology that could enable developing
countries to grow sustainably
furthermore some corporations are also
adopting what they call a triple bottom
line which is concerned not just with
profits but also with respecting people
and the planet nextly gender in ecology
eco-feminist contend that the same
patriarchal attitude of dominance that
is historically harmed women and racial
and ethnic minorities is now harming
nature as well such advocates suggest
that gender theory can provide useful
insights for fostering ecological
sustainability eco-feminist emphasized
the inter dependency between humans in
nature rather than placing humans in a
hierarchical relation in the natural
world again poverty in ecology if I were
mental degradation disproportionately
farms those who are materially for those
in poverty tend to be particularly
vulnerable to floods droughts food
shortages and public health crises thus
as karen baker fletcher argues in one of
our assigned readings those who care
about the poor have a particular reason
for attempting to mitigate environmental
crises on the other hand many developing
nations contend that their best hope for
alleviating poverty on a large scale is
undertaking ecologically destructive
forms of industrialism industrialization
in this situation human poverty and
ecological integrity seemed rather to be
directly at odds now I will also touch
on two of our upcoming games that we
have not yet studied human rights in
ecology a key issue in the discussions
of ecological sustainability is whether
future humans have rights that can
impinge upon our own present behavior if
for example such future person possess a
right to live in a natural environment
no worse off than the present world and
we are now under a serious moral
obligation to live sustainably second
rights issue with relevance for the
natural world is whether non-human
animals have rights as well the reading
assignments for this week by Kent
Greenawalt as well as mary evelyn tucker
and John Grimm addressed these issues
both about obligations to future humans
and to the nonhuman animal world and
lastly international relations and
ecology ecologically unsustainable
practices are leading to a depletion of
Natural Resources within specific
nations as states become increasingly
desperate to obtain such resources it is
practically inevitable that the future
will hold more conflicts like the
highly-anticipated water wars in the
Middle East in northern Africa or in
southern Asia on the other hand nations
across the world are coming to recognize
that addressing global environmental
crises requires canedo dakshin by all
states the urgency of these ecological
concerns is thus driving nations into
partnerships of necessity this concludes
my sketch of how ecological issues
impact and are impacted by other themes
from our course my aim is surveying
these lines of influence is to highlight
the complex relations between the
various topics that we are studying in a
prior version of this course students
were particularly animated by one of the
phrases that Professor wolf used in an
earlier lecture he said all mono causal
explanations our suspect the students
found that kind of piece of academia
amusing and they had it printed up on
t-shirts and they put
on a coffee mug that they gave to him
they enjoyed reciting that phrase
throughout the course I want to suggest
a similar kind of phrase that that's
relevant to this our situation here I
want to say that all mono focal analyses
are suspect and by that I mean any
attempt to understand or to evaluate
just one aspect of faith in
globalization in isolation from these
other aspects will be seriously
inadequate the themes that we study in
this course mutually inform and
influence one another and an adequate
situation of evaluation requires us to
have some facility in discussing all of
them because our course tends to treat
them singly I wanted to pause here just
to show you their model their
inter-relationships now in the second
half of my remarks I will illustrate
some of the resources that faiths
provide for helping people to think
about to care about and to stick with
ecological sustainability I will name
three challenges that impede people from
acting for ecological sustainability and
I will suggest one religious resource
that addresses each of those challenges
before laying out these elements however
I wish to offer two caveats first though
I will focus on the positive influences
that faiths may have and causing people
to care for the environment I certainly
acknowledge that face can also promote
ecologically destructive behavior as
long ago as 1967 Lynn white jr. famously
laid the blame for the modern ecological
crisis at the feet of Christians in
particular I am aware of such claims
second though I will focus on the way
that people of faith can promote
ecological sustainability I acknowledge
that those who claim no personal faith
can likewise pursue the same goal you
may raise either of these issues during
the QA but I have chosen to avoid these
matters here merely for the sake of
brevity now as to the challenges of
ecologically sustainable living a one
distinctively intellectual barrier to
getting people to understand ecological
sustainability is the human difficulty
of thinking about matters on such large
physical and temporal scales some
cognitive psychologists argue that it is
rather unnatural for humans to think on
such scales because our brains are
attuned to
local and short term planning that would
have been sufficient for a hunter
gatherers existed on the African
savannah Gus Speth who I quoted earlier
holds that humans have a very difficult
time comprehending ecological issues in
which the impact of people's actions is
far removed from the space in which the
the agent is acting so although in
earlier times it might have been obvious
not to pollute where we were living
people can follow the impacts there with
things like persistent organic
pollutants that get into the environment
and travel far distances we have a
rather hard time like wrestling with the
reality of this circumstance I contend
the face can help people develop an
imagination with which to think on these
large and physical timescales such an
imagination is promoted by teaching
people to orient themselves within a
cosmology Tucker and gram described in a
reading for today that a cosmology
provides an account of humanity's place
within the universe and a story about
the origin and the end of the story
people of faith tend to situate
themselves within the long lineage of
time and the vast reaches of space with
this imaginative capacity to think big
people of faith can attend to ecological
issues exercising a mental aptitude for
contemplating massive and long-term
concerns vishuddha Narayan on
illustrates in one of our reading
assignments the religious potential for
ecological thinking she shows how the
Hindu tradition and narrative Lee link a
lack of Dharma or righteousness with the
destruction of the earth a second
challenge to ecological sustainable
living is motivational in nature how can
we get people to care about ecological
sustainability when appeals to
self-interest have a limited power in
reforming behavior we can probably
convince people to replace their
incandescent light bulbs with compact
fluorescents on the grounds of this
switch would save them money in the long
term but in circumstances where
promoting ecological sustainability
would result in long-term financial loss
what reason is there for a person to do
the green thing threads with ecological
of eventual ecological collapse often
seem too unlikely or too far away to
compel people to alter their behavior
now faiths can provide a motivational
resource for promoting ecologic
sustainability faiths tend to claim
moral authority for their teachings
about how one should live in other words
they supply people with an ultimate
reason for acting that trumps all other
values including the value of
self-interest the moral reasoning of a
theist may fit on a bumper sticker God
says it I believe it that settles it or
as Narayan on asks rhetorically on
behalf of the Hindu tradition quote if
the entire universe is divine how can we
bring ourselves to pollute it these
simple and straightforward logics
provide billions of people around the
world with non-negotiable duties that
they feel compelled to uphold thus if
people of faith are convinced that it is
morally required of them to live in an
ecologically sustainable manner those
people have overriding motivations to do
so even at great personal expense people
of faith are thus well suited for
helping to broaden the conversation
about ecological sustainability into the
realm of morality scholars are
increasingly calling for ethical
treatments of ecological problems as a
supplement to standard scientific and
economic analyses for example mary
evelyn tucker states here leaders from
both science and policy fields are
realizing that a broader sense of vision
and values is missing while science and
policy approaches are of course
necessary they are not sufficient to
address transforming human consciousness
and behavior for a sustainable future
values and ethics religion and
spirituality are important factors in
this transformation finally even for
those who understand and who care about
ecological sustainability there remains
a difficulty in persevering in this
effort it is easy for those who pursue a
sustainable lifestyle to become
overwhelmed by the magnitude the
consequences and the apparent
intractability of the world's ecological
problems when you add in the
intransigence of those who close their
eyes and shut their ears to the troubles
it is unsurprising that many people
experience what what has been called
green fatigue or eco exhaustion for many
people environmental active
eventually leaves them feeling
environmental that's Michael Pollan an
advocate of ecological sustainability
says quote environmental despair is easy
environmental hope is much harder to
nurture I contend that faiths can supply
this rare quality of hope that would
help encourage people to continue their
personal efforts at promoting ecological
sustainability faiths ground such hope
in assurances that no good deed is
without worth or that the good will
eventually triumph over evil in the long
run of history environmental philosopher
Roger Gottlieb has stated that
ecological desperation can be overcome
by a religious faith that bestows on
each ethical act a cosmic value
independent of practical results it was
religiously grounded hope that propelled
people of faith to oppose slavery in
America and to oppose British rule in
India while the odds were clearly
against such people these activists
persevered in the hope of victory the
ecological challenges facing humanity
today are likewise great but faiths can
certainly serve as one source of
persevering hope and seeking an
ecologically sustainable future in
summary then I have claimed that face
can powerfully engage the head the heart
and the hands of those who are seeking
to promote ecological sustainability
phase can serve as a source of
imagination of motivation and a
perseverance in addressing environmental
issues faced can supply a cosmology that
helps people to cope with ecological
issues on a mind-boggling scale faith
can exert moral authority that motivates
self sacrifice on behalf of the natural
world and lastly
Bates can encourage ecological resolve
through a promise of hope for a better
future I wish to emphasize just one
final observation before I closed and
this is a point that Professor both was
subjugating the exam stick for me to
share yeah sorry it's coming through
that okay
they're professor involve was
particularly excited for me to share
this final point it seems to me that
these same resources that I've just
addressed these resources that help
people of faith to pursue ecological
sustainability are the very same
resources that make faiths potentially
dangerous and destructive forces in
civic affairs in most of our class
discussions you students have been quick
to highlight the problematic
consequences of what you've called
exclusivist or extremist or
fundamentalist faiths you've suggested
that adherence of such faiths are
problematic precisely because they show
moral certainty and unwillingness to
compromise and a readiness to sacrifice
on behalf of their faith I wish to point
out that these qualities which seem
vices in certain situations can also be
virtues when directed against fighting
to protect the natural world if the
ecological crises that we are facing
today are even half as severe as some
people are warning then what the world
needs most right now is uncompromising
moral seriousness and a spirit of
self-denial there may be other sources
for these attitudes but faiths certainly
provide one obvious and popular source
of them